what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
breaking down the complete history of
the holy war including all of the known
events that led up to the war over three
thousand years ago as well as how the
conflict unfolded and how it finally
ended I hope that having all of this
information right here in one place will
be useful to you and that you will be
able to just come back to this video
whenever you have additional questions
about the holy war and its impact on the
current 7th at least in storyline if you
enjoy the seven deadly sins content on
this channel and you'd like us to keep
it going please leave a like to let me
know and if you happen to be new to
anime uproar don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell
seriously though the way that YouTube
works now if you don't want to miss our
videos you have to click that
notification bell and make sure to click
off the option that says turn on all
notifications if you don't do that you
will not be notified that's just YouTube
in the current year you can also follow
me on Twitter and Instagram at anime
uproar for all the latest 7 that lee
sin's news and updates including news on
the new season of the seven deadly sins
anime and finally this video will
contain some spoilers beyond what the
anime has covered so far I will be using
all of the information that we have from
the manga about the holy war and
everything that happened during the holy
war so with that in mind please proceed
with caution you have been warned we
first learned a true story of the holy
war from 3,000 years ago when droll and
gloxinia decide to share their memories
of the holy war with King and the end at
this point the droll and gloxinia had
come to respect King in the end as the
representatives of their clans 3,000
years after they themselves became
members of the ten commandments and were
sealed away inside the coffin of eternal
darkness
however drooling gloxinia explained that
while King and the N can defeat
lower-level demons at their current
level of power they don't stand a chance
against demons who are as strong as the
ten commandments for this reason droll
and gloxinia decide to train and test
King at the end but they do it in a very
unique way King and the N find
themselves transported into the bodies
of Glocks
and roll and they find themselves living
out the lives of wok cine and roll
during the holy war three thousand years
ago so basically the souls of King and
Deanne have somehow been sent into the
past and into the bodies of Roxana and
role and if they don't make the right
choices inside the bodies of these
strangers King at the end will suffer
the consequences in their own bodies as
well it is definitely a high stakes game
but it is also a great vehicle for
showing us what really happened three
thousand years ago right after being
transported into the bodies of drol and
Roxy Nia Deanne and King meet up with
Melly Otis and Elizabeth in her original
goddess body the Melly Otis and
Elizabeth from 3,000 years ago urged
Drona gloxinia to join them for a stigma
mission and this is when we realized
that at this point during the holy war
drawling gloxinia were not members of
the ten commandments instead they were
both part of stigma the Alliance of
humans goddesses Giants and fairies who
fought against the demons during the
holy war during their mission meliodas
strollin gloxinia managed to defeat cal
Maggio's a former member of the ten
commandments who was at the time a
current member in the meantime
elizabeth manages to talk a bunch of
demons into going home basically using
her unique goddess abilities to
essentially charm the demons and make
them lose their will to fight this shows
us that even at this point in history
Elizabeth wanted to avoid killing others
as much as possible and this includes
the demons after this battle against
commodious and the demons drol gloxinia
meliodas and elizabeth meet a human
named ro and several of his human
comrades the humans thanked meliodas and
the others for defeating the demons and
saving them and they asked to be allowed
to join stigma gloxinia droll and the
others agree and they take the humans
back to the secret stigma headquarters
this is important because without the
help of drol gloxinia and the others
these humans would not have been able to
find the stigma headquarters because it
was carefully hidden inside the fairy
kings forest when everyone arrives at
stigma HQ one of the four Archangels
Ludo shell a high-ranking member of the
goddess clan announces that the
conclusion of the holy war is finally at
hand
Elizabeth becomes hopeful when she hears
this and she asks if this means that
stigma is finally going to negotiate for
peace with the demons but Ludo shell
rebukes her right away instead Ludo
shell replies that the time has come to
exterminate all the demons by force the
holy war will end when every last demon
is gone from this world and there is no
one else left to fight now in terms of
the battlefield stats the stigma
Alliance which includes humans fairies
Giants and goddesses outnumbers the
demons by quite a bit
but demons are exceptionally strong by
nature and especially the higher rank
demons such as the ten commandments and
the six nights of black you'll know
exactly who the six nights of black are
if you've seen the seven deadly sins
prisoners of the sky movie although to
be fair they did not end up being nearly
as impressive as I expected them to be
once we actually got to see them in
action during the stigma meetup row the
human who followed drove Roxana and the
others into the stigma headquarters
notices that despite being a member of
stigma meliodas is actually a demon
however ro can tell that despite being a
demon meliodas is a good person which
demonstrates that ro is aware that this
war is not just black and white unlike
say Ludo she'll people like ro and
Elizabeth are able to see that not all
demons are evil PS yes ro looks a lot
like an ancient version of baan but no
he is not directly related to bond as
far as we know at some point Elizabeth
tries to talk Ludo shell out of
exterminating the demons and she
attempts to convince him that not all
demons are bad there are good demons and
bad demons just like there are good
Giants and bad Giants good humans and
bad humans and so on but Ludo shell says
that the demon clan are the excrement of
worms and insects they are inferior
life-forms Ludo shell believes that
wiping the demons out of existence would
actually be doing them a favor because
they are such filthy creatures that they
don't even deserve to exist Ludo shell
also tells Elizabeth to reconsider being
with meliodas
and to find a more suitable partner but
Elizabeth refuses and she storms off
this exchange between Elizabeth and Ludo
shell is very important and it tells us
a lot about the nature of the holy war
and how it might have started we still
don't know exactly how the holy war
started but we do know that the conflict
stems from the mutual hatred between the
demon
and the goddess clan and the mutual
hatred between the ruler of the goddess
clay and the supreme deity and the ruler
of the demon clay and the demon king the
conflict between these two clans has
been ongoing for an unspecified but
extremely long period of time and as we
know eventually the other clans and
races were caught up in it and the holy
war began at first it is easy for us to
assume that the demons are the bad guys
and that stigma are the good guys after
all
if everyone else is allied against the
demons it must mean that there is
something wrong with these demons and
since our first introduction to the Ten
Commandments and to the demons in
general was as the villains of the story
it isn't hard for us to conclude that
the goddesses and the others are good
and the demons are universally evil and
bad however lunar shells exchange with
Elizabeth is a major clue that things
aren't quite as simple as all that we
know that generalizing a large group of
people is always a bad idea because
every person is an individual and there
is no way that every member of a large
segment of the population would be the
same saying that all men are a certain
way or that all Americans are a certain
way or that all members of a particular
race are a certain way is inevitably
going to be a sweeping generalization
that doesn't accurately describe all the
diverse members of this population so
when we hear lunar shells smearing all
demons without exception as the
excrement of insects who deserve to die
we are instantly forced to step back and
rethink this idea that the goddesses are
good and the demons are bad
if the goddesses were really
fundamentally good how could one of
their most important leaders make such a
sweeping and bloodthirsty declaration
something is clearly not right with ludo
shell and by extension with the
goddesses this sentiment is only
confirmed further when Luna shell baits
the demons into attacking stigma by
using a bunch of other demons he
captured as hostages we soon learned
that these captured demons are actually
the demon equivalent of civilians these
are not soldiers or fighters these are
demons who did nothing wrong but they
were captured by the goddesses and used
explicitly as a tool to lure the
stronger demons into a trap
once the demons find stigma and they
attack meliodas tries to talk to them in
an attempt to stop the conflict
Mellie Otis was once on the side of the
demons and a member of the tent
manments but his love for Elizabeth made
him realize that this conflict is
pointless and even though he switched
sides and abandoned the demons his true
goal is to stop the conflict entirely he
wants to end the war before all the
races are senselessly wiped out at this
point Rowe and his human comrades
offered to protect the fairy Kings
forest while gwak's inia and relieved to
help Mellie Otis and Elizabeth try to
negotiate a peaceful solution elizabeth
puts herself on the line by standing in
front of the demons and trying to
convince them not to attack Elizabeth
was not aware that tens of thousands of
innocent demons were abducted and are
currently being held as hostages by the
goddesses and she assures the demons
that she just wants to end the war as
soon as possible but as Elizabeth is
speaking to Derry area and the other
demons trying to find a peaceful
solution to the conflict Lou Rochelle
declares that Elizabeth has done a great
job of buying them time as he says this
a giant Ark is used to instantly kill
all the demon hostages who have been
abducted including dairy Ares sister
right after that most of the lower
demons who were lured into this trap
when the hostages are taken out by two
other Archangels tauriel and sorry el
and their Omega Ark but five of the
commandments managed to survive the
attack these Commandments proceeded to
fight the two Archangels but there is no
clear winner Ludo shell decides to join
the battle and he leaves the goddess
narrow basta in charge of protecting the
gate that leads to the celestial realm
which is the home of the goddess clan
however at this point the doll go third
the goal that we know as one of the
seven deadly sins today shows up and
uses invasion to trick Nero basta
he convinces her that he is Ludo shell
and he tells her to open the gate to the
celestial realm as Ludo shell makes his
appearance on the battlefield
Darry Aryan Mons speed realized that all
will be lost
if they don't take the ultimate step
they decide to sacrifice six of their
seven hearts in order to turn themselves
into indira the mythical berserk demonic
beasts that are far more powerful than
ordinary demons in fact the Endura forms
are so powerful that their Aryan man
speeds succeed in overpowering Ludo
shelfs Arielle antar mio all
in order to become the Endura they were
forced to sacrifice their reason and
self-control so at this point they're
just berserk wild beasts the raging
battle looks like it's going to destroy
the entire fairy Kings forest but then
Elizabeth steps up and vows to stop this
she puts herself in front of their Aryan
man speed and faces off against them but
instead of trying to defeat the Ender a
beast
Elizabeth vows to save them this again
emphasizes the difference between
someone like Elizabeth and someone like
Ludo shell
despite the fact that they are both
high-ranking members of the goddess clan
their opinions on the holy war and on
the demons as a whole are vastly
different this shows us that no large
group of people is exactly the same and
no large group of people will agree on
everything whether they are human demons
or goddesses despite Liu no shells
objections sorry el and Tarmey i'll
decide to support Elizabeth and she uses
her goddess powers to turn mon speed and
arrey arrey back into their normal forms
without killing them the two of them are
knocked unconscious but they are still
alive but this act drains Elizabeth's
energy and she collapses Ludo Sheldon
tries to use this opportunity to finish
off Mon speed in their Airy but droll
and gloxinia stop him they believe that
killing an opponent who cannot move is
wrong and they respect Elizabeth's
tireless efforts to try to end the
conflict without killing anyone else the
Annan King inside the bodies of drawling
gloxinia can't help but think how
warlike some stigma members are and how
they are willing to commit atrocities in
order to trick and trap the demons but
clearly some members of stigma including
Elizabeth and meliodas are very
different Ludo Sheldon contacts niro
basta and tries to get her to summon
Miele the strongest Archangel and other
reinforcements from the celestial realm
but narrow basta has been brainwashed by
Goethe er who at the time was also a
member of the Ten Commandments and
molasse cola' who is another member of
the ten commandments molasse gila
believes that their mission is to
reconstruct the gate so that it connects
to the demon realm instead of the
celestial realm which would allow the
demons to summon their own
reinforcements and win the battle when
he realizes that the gate has been
compromised looter shall commands all of
the other members of stigma including
the fairies giants and humans to storm
the look
of the gate and prevent Golder and
mulaskey law from using it however in
that moment row and the other humans who
recently came to the headquarters of
stigma decide to turn against stigma
they begin brutally killing stigma
members including Giants and fairies
Rowe and his allies revealed that they
actually share a goal in common with the
demons and that goal is the destruction
of stigma back at the gate molasse Kela
thinks that she is changing the gate to
open the portal to the demon realm
instead of the celestial realm but in
reality gothert ricked not only near a
basta but also molasse Kula he
manipulated mulaskey line into opening a
gate to the demon world prison word the
real goal thir the creator of the dog
author was imprisoned for 500 years the
real golfer who is himself a demon is
then able to escape his prison and
immobilize Mel ask allah the real golfer
reveals that he was imprisoned and
forced to help the ten commandments by
the demon king after he initially
refused to take part in the war for five
centuries he could only experience the
outside world through his doll the goal
that we know from the sound of the sins
but the real goal Thurs goal is to be a
free man and to end the holy war the
real goal there is thus another example
of a demon who did not want the war and
who wants to stop the death and
suffering but the real goal that reveals
that in order to put a stop to the war
he will have to sacrifice his life when
he learns from the real goal third that
the humans betrayed stigma King in Block
C Nia's body rushes over to rescue book
senior sister get high at this point it
is revealed why ro and the humans
infiltrated stigmas headquarters and
decided to turn against them
ROS entire village was mercilessly
slaughtered by stigmas some years
earlier and the only reason why all of
the humans within the village were
killed was because a few days earlier
they had found the demon wood collapsed
near the village and they decided to
help him
this particular demon was not a bad guy
and he didn't do anything wrong but just
because they decided to help a demon no
matter who the demon was the entire
village was brutally slaughtered ro and
a few of his friends only survived
because they happened to be hunting in
the mountains at the time so they were
not inside the village when stigma
destroyed it
after that Roy and his friends swore to
become strong and exact their revenge on
stigma but after exacting his revenge
role looks at what they had done he
looks at all the killing and suffering
and he realizes that this makes him and
his friends no different than the people
who destroyed their village once again
this underlines the complexities of this
war and of all wars there are evil
demons but there are also good demons
and there are demons who are just
innocent civilians who are not fighters
or soldiers there are good members of
stigma and there are of course evil
people within stigma who are willing to
slaughter civilians just for helping a
demon and even though Rose swore to
exact his revenge on stigma because they
did something inexcusable after he goes
through with it he realized that he
allowed himself to become the very thing
that he hated he himself became a
merciless killer just like the people
who destroyed his village that's the
thing about war war is not about good
guys and bad guys
war brings death and suffering to
everyone involved King in gloxinia 's
body finds ro holding a bloody and
injured get hey ro had actually saved
get her after one of his friends tried
to kill her but to box and hide looks
like roll was the one who hurt his
sister gloxinia loses it an attacks roll
without even thinking of the
consequences ro throws get had away from
him just in time so that she isn't
caught up in locks in his attack and he
tells her to survive Rose fake smile in
that exact moment reminds King so much
of bond that he stops himself and he
doesn't kill ro but even though King
stops himself the real gloxinia didn't
stop the real gloxinia savagely murdered
ro 3,000 years ago without giving his
sister the chance to explain that role
wasn't the one who hurt her in fact roll
was the one who saved her life in that
moment King passes gloxinia
test and he is returned to his own body
gloxinia reveals that after he killed ro
he lost his mind and turned against
stigma becoming one of the 10
commandments he just assumed that his
sister was dead because of her injuries
and he didn't even bother to check that
she was actually still alive that was
his biggest sin and his greatest regret
King that explains why he didn't kill
role he realized over the course of
life that no one was just purely evil
everyone has their own circumstances
often tragic ones and that makes them do
what they do king could tell that role
meant a lot to get holiday just like
bond meant a lot to Elaine and that is
why he refused to kill him gloxinia says
King passed the test but he is also
naive because he doesn't realize that
true evil does indeed exist back inside
the fairy Kings forest 3,000 years ago
zelgius shows up through the magic gate
and he demands that the original gold
are returned to his cell
Diann and rolls body tells the two
Golders to escape and end the holy war
while she keeps his elders busy droll
and Zelda's begin to fight but Zell just
manages to easily overpowered roll with
a single blow
Zell drous who is the proxy of the demon
king and possesses some of the demon
King's own power offers joel a choice
either die right here and now or join
the 10 commandments zelgius offers to
give drawl even more power if he joins
the commandments and because giant
culture is all about bravery and glory
in battle the real troll could not bring
himself to run away so he chose to join
the commandments and get more power
troll was always an outcast among the
Giants anyway he was always different
but the demons are all outcasts so he
could join them and finally fit in
somewhere this is actually interesting
because it reminds me of how s kannur
joined the seven deadly sins in the
first place s Kannur was also an outcast
who was considered to be a monster by
most other people but the seven deadly
sins were all outcasts in their own way
so I Skinner actually managed to fit
right in with the sins but unlike the
real troll the anand rolls body doesn't
choose death or becoming one of the ten
commandments she does something that
role could never do she just runs away
from Zell drous she was willing to
overcome her sense of pride as a giant
and make the smart choice something drol
could not do and by doing this she also
passes the test and returns to her own
body we later learned a troll actually
became reincarnated as the magical dog
Oslo so that he could always protect
Gare holiday even in his next life after
the events that king in the end
witnessed in gloxinia and roll's bodies
the whole
war did come to an end but King in the
end didn't see how thankfully we did
eventually learn how the real go through
managed to bring the war to an end now
this part of the video will include
major spoilers for some important plot
points that have not been covered in the
anime so if you don't want to know how
the holy war ended because you don't
want to spoil a big twist for yourself
you could step away right now
if you continue watching a big twist
from the manga will be revealed so
seriously proceed with extreme caution
you have been warned
Goethe er used a forbidden spell to
alter the memories of a vast number of
people in order to end the war more
specifically he altered the memories of
the strongest Archangel mile and
everyone who knew him in order to make
them think that mile was actually a
demon called esta rosa and that he was
one of the three sons of the demon king
when in reality the demon king had only
two sons having lost their biggest asset
in the war the strongest archangel miele
who they believed was killed by this
mysterious demon esta rosa the goddess
clan was unable to carry out their plan
of killing all the demons so instead the
goddesses sacrificed their physical
bodies in order to seal all the demons
away inside the coffin of eternal
darkness this effectively ended the war
the two driving forces behind the
conflict the demons and the goddesses
were taken out of the equation the
Giants and fairies were weakened by the
war and retreated to their own
respective realms and the humans were
left to dominate the majority of
Britannia unopposed this stalemate
remained in place for 3,000 years until
the coffin of eternal darkness was
finally broken in the present time the
only other holy war related events that
we have to mention is the fact that some
time before the war ended Elizabeth and
meliodas were cursed by their parents
the supreme deity and the demon king for
choosing to be together rather than
remaining unquestioningly loyal to their
respective clans and we also know that
at some point during the war Merlyn
tricked the supreme deity and the demon
king she convinced both of them to give
her special magical gifts by promising
to support their side during the holy
war however after receiving the gifts
from both side
Merlin decided not to support either
side and as a result the supreme deity
and the demon king decided to destroy
Merlin's hometown of beli allowin the
capital of the Wizards in order to
punish Merlin needless to say
Merlin survived the destruction of her
hometown and she is still alive today
and that is the complete history of the
holy war from 3,000 years ago at least
in terms of all the information that we
actually have available so far there are
of course many gaps and many things that
we don't know including how exactly the
conflict between the demons and the
goddesses started since this holy war
had been raging for a very long time
definitely hundreds and maybe even
thousands of years it is unlikely that
we will ever have a record of every
single event that occurred during the
war although I do hope that we will one
day find out how and why the whole thing
started with that said please let me
know what you guys think how and why did
the rivalry between the goddesses and
the demons start in the first place was
it some drama between the demon king and
the supreme deity maybe even some
romantic drama or was it something else
entirely please give me your thoughts
down in the comments if you enjoyed this
video and you want to see more seven
deadly sins content right here on the
channel please leave a like to let me
know and if you happen to be new to
anime abroad don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications feel free to follow
me on Twitter and Instagram at anime
uproar for all the latest seven deadly
sins news and updates including news on
the new season of the seven deadly sins
anime I want to give a big thank you to
all of our anime out pro patrons who
make videos like this one possible
special thank you to all of our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
King zelgius on hell cruise stealers
poet Pablo
atropos Wraith fitted alibied a karate
Gian Anatole Cassatt's ki DJ Nathaniel
and alpha do and I can't forget the ones
that rise above all other clans a
massive thank you to all of our the one
tier patrons including in grata alone
Adam Maddy Mac makoto-kun and your boys
Seth if you enjoy our videos and you
think that they add some value to your
life consider supporting us on patreon
even a single dollar will give you a
says to our patron exclusive discord and
your name will appear in our videos
along with these amazing people as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see us bass
Cowboys
[Music]